welcome to this video against mr. Rolex
okay from from Norway talk beyond our
Henson okay guys playing this g5 line
which I don't know I know you are ok 780
won't dad so I just play the normal line
which is probably not exactly
devastating for black but it's not so
bad at the test been played burkas power
off at least so it shouldn't be
shouldn't be completely terrible um I so
don't know how it is exactly played
maybe still with h4 I have okay this
changes the structure of course getting
into a stone ball type of position
should i play edge 496 is interesting
maybe it's trying to quickly prepare ye
five okay i think i can hardly do
without c4 in the long run of course the
night on d 2 it's not so really no e six
maybe now maybe you can do that
looks a bit strange but now taking 95
it's not clear that this is so great for
me now each other just develop and I'd
like to play h4h 4g 495 he always has 9
h 50 on this type of position
something else entirely yeah we're we're
to e2 or b12 probably hear hard to same
with the little time
this neglects the five square though not
so sure what this is doing Nyjah for a
die before okay so if you want to really
put it on a 6 mm okay okay first first
go here try to provoke this G for
business wow this looks entirely
unplayable to be honest
I could excellent square control let's
prevent each 59 bishop on f4 I mean how
the how do you ever challenged the g5
noid okay I'll just just push him queen
bee three was also good and now before
maybe I'm just just gain space okay if
maybe maybe like this I can I can even
put put this here on a five-play be five
not sure that I need to castle age five
is is under tech so okay we will now see
seven is Sarah I could have actually
taken or whatever night g6 this is
detect or take here now maybe maybe this
one even though I can just take him then
take c 7 a-1 Hanks but c7 is just a
complete as good a complete piece him a
full piece
check
okay let's see I mean this is almost
trapped here and i have d 6 of course d
6 dome now let's first attack that I've
aft six and where is he going with the
bishop
okay so i can also just take on g4 him
hmm no no this is not bad but okay it's
a piece it's not not necessary to to
rush anything
I'm just trying to to prepare the some g
for business taking them until
everything so correctly placed maybe
maybe it's better to even take on e4
going to be one and then take on you for
then g-form yeah i'm not sure if it was
the best possible way to prepare it yeah
maybe not
yeah but it's it's quite a number of
pawns so I can give a couple of checks
for just and then again even Jack bones
check check here that's really a lot of
chance check I'm not sure yet how to do
it maybe it's just to get the Queen back
into my camp check check check check
check
yeah this looks fairly safe
guindy one Quincy to us a check even
black rosanna I cannot even avoid the
Queen trade if he goes on the
second-ranked somewhere like like here
there's always Quincy to check yeah this
wasn't a good technical play honey g3
was a bad move I mean I mean it should
be winning in any case but g3 is just
bad it makes it more difficult I should
just stay put him with the Jeep on and
so that I have f3 yet the right now g3
is really bad I mean before that this
this position is just just very bad for
black I have those excellent pieces and
tease got so many weaknesses I would
need to paint paint the hulking side
here it's not not good at all and here
we are now x tier 96 was possible
already taking hear the ticking of the
night winds in exchange yeah this is
this is even even worse ig3 was really
bad completely unnecessary makes it
funny the computer wants to play g3 as
well it's really bad I mean after that I
only have this sacrifice to to break
through and maybe if I want to sec I
should do it right now I mean this is
probably the best point to do it it's a
three pawns and basically no attack for
black yeah this is also better than what
I played ok thanks for watching